[Music]
this wasn't staged for the cameras
northern ireland's air ambulance is
responding to a live call
the crew's mission as always is to
preserve life
minutes later they're putting this
training into practice
incubating a patient okay folks so just
to recap of where we are
obviously we've extricated this patient
he's fallen 24. every day begins with
this kind of exercise
and ppe has brought unique challenges
one of the biggest challenges is
communication you know i'm talking to
you tomorrow with normal tone of voice
but how to raise that up whenever we're
speaking and particularly in an aircraft
we're wearing our helmets we're wearing
these
masks so i'm talking to the pilot
talking to the doctor
and sometimes you've got to again speak
louder and
really reliant upon effective
communication
belfast stand by for details it isn't
long before they're doing it for real
ambulance headquarters in belfast is
requesting the helicopter emergency
medical service
they quickly deploy from their base
formerly the site of northern ireland's
notorious maze prison
from this place long associated with
death they are
saving life but the pandemic poses a
real threat
in the confined space of an aircraft
within five minutes of the 999 call this
crew can be on board
and ready for departure but it doesn't
matter what kind of incident they're
responding to they now have to
assume that every patient is covered
positive
covert has increased the number of
incidents they're keen to ease the
pressure on their land colleagues
rooftop landings at the royal victoria
hospital have become routine
but increased isolation during lockdown
has changed the nature of calls
they're dealing with an upsurge in
life-threatening injuries
caused by attempted suicide a variety of
traumatic injuries that are a result of
mental health and
the stresses of society dealing with the
coveted pandemic and we are able to
to bring interventions airway secure
ongoing cpr you know for prolonged
arrests
and it's certainly probably one of the
stark things i've noticed while there's
maybe been a dip
in some of the road traffic collisions
that we attend
they're not the front line in the fight
against covid they're a critical
backline trauma doesn't stop during a
pandemic
tomorrow will bring different challenges
for northern ireland's air ambulance
team
david blevins sky news at the maze